tiens véritables explorateurs des temps
modernes qui tente de gravir le sommet
du k2 savez ce que c'est que le cas dans
l'himalaya
voilà himalaya nîmes alaïa et c'est pas
celui de dorothée c'est pas les neiges
eux des noms assez l'himalaya je vous
dirai ce que vous avez déjà gravis
quelque chose ou à parent toblerone
alors et c'est quand même le deuxième
plus haut sommet de la planète derrière
les vrais ce tu t'arrêtes pas là et tu
traverses l'océan arctique en passant
par le pôle nord
c'est la troisième fois que tente de
gravir le cas de oui malheureusement ne
sait pas toujours moi qui décide il faut
vraiment écouter un peu la nature du
foie la nature est toujours plus fort
que nous a bien sûr un piano en effet
blanc fait puis dès qu'on arrive à 8000
mètres et on a plus d'oxygène parce que
j'ai grand pas avec les cordes avec
richert pas avec l'oxygène des groupes
saluant comme ça un supermarché à sa
femme chérie nous dire il va acheter du
pain à lui dit cherry devait grimper du
mariage revient de ma faim et puis là
quand à que ces poissons d'oxygène on
peut rester vivant que 24 heures dans
cette zone de mort et puis en plus si tu
tu réfléchis plupart et moi j'ai vu des
femmes à poil volet avec
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
s'il n'a pas complètement à la poêle
mais la poêle mais voilà les crêtes
contaminé crète pour des classes et non
mais se règle et mike horn et il ya
toujours été comme ça peut passer
toujours été un peu aventurier est aussi
jessica où je pense que c'est un peu
dans les jeunes mais ouais pas à
l'extrême que non et bien sûr mais ça tu
vas peut-être y arriver mais est-ce que
déjà nettement raté et le qe2 ça veut ça
ne m'intéresse pas encore mais combien
tu peux te plains vient je fais le camp
de base pour la fin mai jessica c'est
toujours là là philippe au lancement du
plus jeune et piété au pôle nord quand
elle à utah eu quoi 13 12 en deux ans
ils ont raison ils voulaient aller en
2001 puis je le disais mais je la mène
là où il ya des centaines et puis ils
seront ils ont préparé leur expédition
j'étais des vêtements power lit sartre
couchage et chaussures ils sont commencé
tous les matins de s'entraîner avec moi
pour une période d'une année
on a fait la préparation après on
appartient avec un hélico russe qui ne
posait sur la glace et puis à 12 et 13
ans c'est c'est toujours les plus jeunes
enfants qui a qui arrivait au paul
c'est sympa mais ça veut dire que moi je
pouvais pas l'amener en 2000 l'âme mais
jouer
[Applaudissements]
la corde puis et son fils où il y avait
moi disney en photo comme au pôle nord
de cailler les miches à ma vie et à la
question vous avez tout fait ce qui est
encore une aventure un exploit que vous
rêvez de faire avant de mourir un
exploit incroyable que vous rêvez de
faire il y à des exploits peut-être pas
sur terre mais quand on regarde un peu
mars
oui mais ça c'est une bille est allé sur
terre saab sur terre il encore dit des
choses
au fond on lit marin de la mer
au fond dans les pays où on connaît très
très peur du fond marin et pays c'est
pour ça je pense aujourd'hui c'est
encore là seul endroit
il craint papa exploit